[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on you guys
and today i have a very special panel
man we have a very special
show in case you ain't noticed the
topics
it's gonna be a little bit of a messy
show man and guess what
laura cardinal ain't around to stop it
we we have officially
silenced thor cognito on the attic show
he cannot stop us
this is my realm you know like in the
animes where you walk into like a little
diameter and it's
it it's like they're not allowed for
this particular show cognito is not
allowed to stop this
so we're going to be talking about the
how strong
xbox exclusives seem to be going on
we're going to be talking about
the coalition seems to be working on a
non-gears title i want the the panels
you know kind of criteria with that
we're going to talk about the xbox
lineup for the next year year and a half
uh so first off
king david has joined us
obviously if it's something like this
man we got to get king david on here
what's going on king david you know what
it is
it's a tuesday's reset day we out here
ready to smash pumpkins let's go
smash pumpkins oh geez man
we there man we there then we got k mega
from the grg podcast what's going on man
what's happening man you know uh when
the call got sent
i was like oh somebody wants some of
that delicious slander today so i was
like all right
i'm here i'm here so and now we got king
david in the building so yeah now it's
it might be pretty brutal for the
opposite for the opposing side but we go
we're going to keep it we're going to
keep it honest it's always brutal for
them what you talking about
in case you ain't noticed the past
probably a year man
it ain't safe to come outside for them
it's been awfully quiet i'm seeing
people talk about the cracking
uh and it used to be the kraken was
lacking but i guess that could be going
to the kraken is lacking over there
because they ain't got no memory over
there so i don't know oh my god
i don't know i don't know that memory
yeah yeah that was people talking about
they fill in that space and they're dead
space in the console they're trying to
make an excuse to say well sony doesn't
need to give the
you said exclusive exclusives yeah yeah
yeah you got an exclusive
hole in the box i've seen a couple of
them come out and say
well the kraken because if you compare
if you look at the difference between
how many gigs goes into the xbox series
x and you know how many goes into
into the playstation 5 you see that the
kraken is is a beast
oh so all right let's do it none of
these people even played ct that's the
funny part
so first off i think uh you know i
definitely want to talk about this
statement that sean layton made he was
talking about
whether or not you know uh game pass
is sustainable not only necessarily
money-wise but
you know from making a diverse of a
library-wise and
you know the i want to go to keem first
on this because i know
king is the king of
the game pass lander he he he's pretty
much
for for the past two years he's been
giving us
a road map of how game pass is gonna do
what game pass but besides the
you know the cd projekt red you know
that didn't happen we ain't gonna go
into that
so we're gonna we're gonna king exactly
what is your response of what did you
think when you first saw leighton's
comment about this well i was happy he
was alive
um because i was i was thinking jimmy
hoffa
you know we never saw that man again i'm
like
is shawn buried in giant stadium too oh
my god
i was looking for the man i was worried
for the man but uh
shawna came out of his hidey hole and
and it takes something as big as game
pass to remove from from his dark spaces
you understand it takes something very
incredible
to remove you from the hidden zone
he was banished and your man stuck his
head out to say game pass ain't it
how you hear about it where you was that
that's what i want to know
if it ain't it why are you worried about
it if it ain't
it why are you trying to scream and tell
people it ain't it
you know what it is this this is this is
where fear sits and you understand fear
and you can smell it because somebody
will yell out something
random that has absolutely nothing to do
with them they'll yell out something
around
and you know exactly where their fear
lies oh you need 500 million subscribers
or something ridiculous
to make you believe something that is
not true
they told you before that the game pass
can't be sustainable
they told you before that game pass will
only have uh
what is this um shovelware and the game
pass will be the land of broken games
they told you
all types of things but at the end of
the day game pass has been the home of
first party games that
didn't release on their console for free
and we got it for free
game pass has been the home of uh day
and dates people never saw day and days
happening and these are day and nights
and day and dates and triple a titles
they told you that it wouldn't be
sustainable to have your first party
titles launched it because
your company can't survive your company
can't survive
so eddie carrier do it out of curiosity
i kind of want to work back a little bit
when he's talking about like the
diversity thing in terms of type of
games that goes into this platform are
you out of your mind
he obviously didn't step in and put his
head fully
into the part of gamepad so it is
absolutely completely
hundred percent yeah that that's what i
want to really capitalize on is like
i don't i i don't really understand the
concept and what he was talking about
here because like to me
what i when i look at game pass there's
a lot of diversity types of genres only
diversity
and that's that's the part that like
kind of like makes me scratch my head
the most because i'm just like
does this do has this dude ever looked
at game pass like
no he was in he was banished bro like
i'm telling you right he was sent off to
nardia that's what he's saying yeah
nardia oh my god
so sonia if they threw him into the
cover man they just like
you don't got to go home but you can't
come here like you know
was quiet man that's why he got his
devotion he's quiet he's talking about
indies man so
your [ __ ] your [ __ ] got the you have the
whole yakuza series over there
it's rpg heaven it's first person
shooter heaven
it's strategy games they're indie games
that are so diverse
all right so here uh i'm gonna i'm gonna
put up the app for just pc keep in mind
chat goes
this is just pc we're not even looking
at the the apps for you know everything
so if we look at this you know clearly
it's got a little bit
i mean look at all this diversity like i
just don't
i just you got all the the the
dishonoreds you got the dead spaces
obviously that's the ea access
but you you still have access to it
because the game pass ultimate
you know you got the doom so that's
first person shooters you got
um you know i just played roger the 694
the game was ridiculous
that's like a strategy game you got the
fallout some more first-person shooters
platformers you got these jrpgs
racing games racers fighters i'm just
i'm looking at this and i'm just like
what world did this do live like i feel
like he didn't think
i feel like in the phantom zone yeah i
feel like he panicked
answered if that makes sense to you like
he panicked fanboy dance
yeah you're probably right he probably
it's a difference it's very hard to see
that you've been booted out by that the
same dude
that you shared the stage with and i
told you guys watch very closely
how my man stood in the middle and he
exited out both people on the side
foul he both both of them bow out of
there
him and reggie gone but at the same time
it's very hard to see somebody that
if you felt that you was able to compete
with and you wasn't given a chance to
because your numbers and your situation
wasn't right and the philosophies
changed and they changed and switched up
on
you and to see right now game passing
xbox is about to do something that
sean felt that if he was in position
that would never have happened
you understand it's very hard for you to
swallow that pill
that you are not in the fight you are
not in the fight you are not engaged you
were silenced
he was shut and he was thrown in the
corner and he did a lot of work over
there
he made them very prominent so you don't
think that during this period of time
you're looking at what's going on over
there he's like what's happening
and all he can say is that his presence
has been removed you don't think he hear
people say
uh jim dance moves ryan needs to be gone
he's like yeah i was in that spot
why did you take me out i mean i've
never had i've never seen a petition to
get sean
layton out and then you know you can
look at it from the standpoint that when
all of the you know the pc stuff came
out on the open
and uh you know homeboy's been drove
through the dirt a little bit jim dansby
of ryan's like
sean was liking all of these posts on
twitter so like clearly
he's he is a little bit bitter on what
happened over there and like wouldn't
you be
oh i i was better for him i have to be
in that situation i'm already bitter for
it
like because people thought i was joking
around when i was saying where's sean
like you your daughter was joking around
i want to beat the champ
you understand i want to beat the champ
at his finest i want to beat the champ
in his prime
i don't want to beat the champ when he
he doesn't
lost weight off of keto i don't want
that i don't want
that i don't want that champ that's not
the dude so
this is going to be an easy ko and it's
not the dude
that we wanted the ko no uh uh no
because
jim ryan you can tell right off the bat
that he is the person that is listening
to the upper management sean
seemed like he gave a little bit of
pushback and
the one thing that playstation fans uh
or i should call them stands
what they felt on was off the greatness
of what playstation did
from the few games that they that they
presented that got everybody hyped over
right like and that
there's nothing you can't take anything
away from that but playstation also
lived up that old trope
basically saying oh you know
single-player single-player games
they're about to be out of there phil
spencer ea all the industry they want to
get rid of
single-player games and so not only the
not only the fans
media sided with that was going to go
ahead and give single players
all the glory all of this and sean
layton benefited
off of a lot of mistakes that microsoft
made in the last gen
but they were preparing and they said
that once phil got in he said look we're
going to make it right
it's just it's going to take time now
you know this also this is hold over
this is one thing too that this is
pretty crazy is that
um playstation is having another slow
start just like they did
last gen the difference was because of
xbox
the whole drm thing the price
differences and things like that
remember there was people telling us the
playstation slim was going to be the
most dominant product on
in the in the gaming space because of
its price range now they're telling you
that nobody wants a a product that's
uh cheaper which are talking about the
series s because
of whatever reasons yeah talk about
little man talk about that nobody wants
little man now because
it's just not as sustainable as as his
counterpart
but if you go and you look at the pro
you look at the place that you look at
the regular playstation
uh the regular playstation and the
playstation slim playstation slim
was product that got bought they got
bought the most
why is it that people aren't looking at
that the same way
and while they'll say people that was
making the case for the playstation slim
aren't making the same case for the
series s
because they're undercutting playstation
it's crazy to me
and then with all of the other uh
problems that
that we're seeing with the management
issues it's something i've been saying
for years
i'm like look microsoft is going through
this situation with the xbox one because
of the turnover
playstation is going to go through the
same thing as well
they can't have all this term when you
have big big wigs like andrew house and
but you know what the difference is
with the turnover from microsoft and the
turnover from sony
oh yeah microsoft the company can absorb
that and absorb it
right sony cannot cannot and and as you
can just look at the acquisitions
everybody else is making all these huge
acquisitions sony says what they're
doing
they're they're they're acquiring
exclusives for for two years
that should tell you something right
there things aren't aren't the same and
then once john legend was saying that
they were doubling down they were gonna
have to cut back because games cost
so much to make which he's absolutely
right about that
we're gonna start giving you more of the
same
which was gonna be lack of diversity and
then i think that's
the head button between upper management
and with charlene and it was like i know
you're out of there yeah
but what he what he didn't have was a
formulated plan to subsidize the force
of triple a titles all right so you've
seen uh games like horizon
and games like god of war uh you know
budgets
start to explode and when these budgets
start to explode
their direct plan uh in uh
subsidizing these titles is to uh cut
content then give you content as forms
of dlc
and uh give you content as far as uh
remasters and up not remastered
yeah yeah remasters and up rez's and uh
holding back content behind paywalls
so that strategy is a failed and a
flawed strategy
right whereas game pass strategy it's uh
it's a winning formula at first you may
look at it as
it's a losing formula but if you throw
all your first parties
inside of the the subscription service
and then you make it you know day-to-day
and those games are available for
purchase
you still have the crowd that's going
out to purchase but then you also
bolster
your subscription service that is
something that sony was unwilling to do
and it's still
unwilling to do because they don't see
the financial gain when it comes to
doing something like that because they
don't have the infrastructure
in doing so microsoft laid that role map
long time ago with the azure cloud
with the azure cloud systems they were
building this
future and they were holding on hoping
that
the parent company would see the strides
that they were making
inside the gaming division once the
gaming division started gaining traction
in a form that it can actually compete
then they actually went
full force behind it you can tell by the
branding and stuff that's going on now
um sony lost faith in charm
sony lost faith in sean because sean
lacked vision sean
i don't was a entertainer i don't
necessarily think that sony lost faith
and
and sean i think he would still be there
well i think
sean i think there's a little bit to
that but i think it was mainly sean lost
the power struggle
like he lost the favor he lost the power
and i think that's what mainly happened
i don't think necessarily like saudi was
like on some
let's get sean up out of there i think
sonia's on like we're having redundant
rows at this point because this dude
has won the favor of the company and and
we've seen it like
clearly that well you get what you get
what i'm saying
i'm saying yeah if you go from somebody
that is that is actually pushing back
and trying to give out
trying to say look my way has been
successful the things that we've been
doing
we've you know said it can work we just
got to sustain it
and then you compare it to somebody
who's jim ryan you know i don't know the
man of course but
it seems like he is more of a person
that listens to what corporate tells him
than him actually laying down you know
some kind of
initiative that to me just tells you
right there they but they just wasn't
agreeing in that
person this is this is where the
boardroom looks
at things the boardroom doesn't see the
things how we see the things right okay
the boardroom sees numbers they see
money they come in there with their
charts they talk about their charts they
talk about
what we did in this quarter that quarter
versus this quarter what was spent what
was acquired and what was made
what was actual uh expenditures and what
was gross incomes and they're looking
for split dividends
when they're doing these things sean
leighton is not the man for that because
sean is going up there as an entertainer
and explaining the grand vision on
how sony can expand in this gym dance
moves ryan comes up there
he's in he's completely a numbers dude
he's been a numbers dude he's always
been a numbers dude
and it's no doubt in my mind that's the
reason why sony has been successful
under his leadership people don't want
to believe that
they're successful but they have been
successful and they're constantly
selling they're doing different numbers
better numbers than when sean was in
place but at the same time they're
consolidating closing down redundant
like you said uh studios that should not
be which sucks which the japan studio
was the
like one of the ones to catch a act but
a lot of those european studios got
closed as well
you understand those things that made
them successful
they are no longer the diversity is that
yes diversity
and you you know it's the crazy let me
get these super chats real quick
uh say flame it weird
flame with the two live super chat where
did uh i'm weirded out by the ray
tracing with that mario king
people still talking about that mario
man we got five dollars from jared mack
just showing la
uh just showing live and support to the
lord salute
definitely appreciate it man then we got
a 10 dollar subtract from optimus code
unchained just showing support brother
definitely appreciate that
look so here's my thing with this i
think
sean definitely might be talking a
little bit of you know
a previous person that worked at sony uh
i think that the difference between sean
and the difference between someone like
phil spencer is
sean was in an environment where the
company wasn't backing something like
game
pass so he did he doesn't see the the
back
hail numbers he doesn't see you know the
success that it's having
uh you know behind the wall so obviously
something
someone like him would automatically
come out and feel like it's not
the answer because his company that he
worked for
did not like that whatsoever so and you
know
he he himself has spoken out that he
doesn't like
subscription-based stuff he likes you
know relying strictly on
the way that sony has always done things
and i'm not saying that
he's wrong because i i do feel like
to a point you know there there might be
some
form of truth behind what he's saying
but i'm saying
from the numbers and what we see game
pass
that kind of shows that he's wrong by
itself you know
clearly they're making money and they
have a lot of faith behind the the brand
microsoft's able to spend the type of
money is required to do something like
game pass
because they have the backing of
microsoft and people always try to bring
up old microsoft
old microsoft old xbox was never
backed 100 like this by microsoft ever
not one time in the entire time they've
ever been around
even when it came to something such as
the 360 when they had to to save it from
the the red ring of death
they did that for the brand they didn't
do it to bro build up the brand they did
it to save the brand
and make microsoft look good because
microsoft has always been hated so
that would if they let that go just like
if they did it with the zoom
and and in in the microsoft phone and
all of that
then the problem would have been you
know
xbox definitely wouldn't recover and
microsoft
uh the company itself would have been
stained behind something like that so
they had to make that move
through every goodbye and what i what i
see the most people was in position you
say steve ballmer who is a passionate
individual
made sure that um as you can see with
what he does with the la clip is
right um he's a very whatever he puts
himself in you want somebody that's in
that position to
give you their all uh it was just a
perfect storm when it came to that
situation that the wrong person wasn't
in that position
um because had it been someone like don
metric
uh you would have you it would
definitely just went under it was
different people that was in
in position at microsoft that was
working against the current flow
of uh what we have now um you have the
right people at the right time in
position
and that's what happened tonight what
you're seeing is you
people perceive sony to have the the
wrong people
in the right positions right now i don't
believe that to be true
you know um i actually believe uh jim
dan's move ryan is gonna do exactly what
he's supposed to do he's supposed to
make money for the company
he's uh bringing those titles over to pc
he's uh destroying those narratives that
are actually holding the company back
you know um the ten percent of
individuals that feel that their voice
is the strongest these are the people
that
feel that oh they have the best interest
of playstation no you have the worst
interest replacements
absolutely all right you're claiming
exclusive it's only exclusive to you
when you buy it um
why do you care why should you care who
else gets the chance to partake of your
game
at any place other than yourself all
right so you're not going out buying
millions you're going out buying one but
you don't concern yourself with that one
you're concerning yourself with millions
that's why they always bring up numbers
because they feel that there's safety in
numbers no i single you out because i
see you as an individual
that doesn't work for the company um jim
knows what works for the company
yeah shout out to nexus and it's like
it's like i said
i was gonna say it's like i said you
know i i'd be talking to king and cog
like what's going to be funny is like
people
talk all the nonsense they want about
jim dance with ryan we make
jokes but i i wouldn't be surprised by
the end of the ps5 if he made more money
off
for them off the playstation brand then
they've ever made an entire generation
like ever because they're gonna they're
gonna keep pushing this it's gonna get
you
to where the sony the sony games will be
coming out day on pc
i i see it because they have no choice
because the more and more that we we
talked about this on grg yeah it's going
to be pretty tough
for xbox to sustain 50 you know 40 to 50
million
at the this year but by next year it is
hit it it could possibly it can
definitely happen
and it happened maybe in the first
quarter this is one of my thoughts it's
like people keep talking about
final fantasy why it's still not on xbox
yet
but if phil spencer and them have you
know have a
trick up their sleeve and they put that
game on xbox i mean on game pass
uh and winning the first second quarter
that's going to rake and that's going to
bring other people to
be invested and even for playstation
fans who has an xbox
they're going to double dip and they're
going to invest into game pad even if
they haven't get
invested at that point because of the
fact that they want to see it and be
and play it and experience it and then
for people who's been asking for final
fantasy 7 remake to come over
or eventually uh i'm still saying like
stoner will eventually go in there i
think atlas is going another direction
they see
where the money is and that they can
just start spreading the wealth all over
to
nintendo to now be over pc or and
they've seen how quick
great uh persona 4's done game pass is
just
it's it's the it's the future it's the
next phase
it's something like when people they're
saying well 70 dollars
and then we're at people that was just
coming you know we had to call the
situation last
last year and we're still having the
situation and that's people that's still
struggling
you're trying to ask for people to you
know people complain about ea and
activision what are they doing but i
mean
you got some people still capping for
the fact that sony is still
acting requiring for you older games to
pay
fifty dollars even if you pay for the
version of go satoshima
and and and and then or pay 70 bucks all
for it because you
partake in buying a playstation 5 and
probably traded in your playstation 4.
and then on top of that
you're telling me that i got to pay an
extra 20 or 10 to 20 dollars
because of haptic triggers that was the
whole reason why i bought the
playstation 5 in the first place
so again this is the thing to me yeah
yeah don't say that man i got it i got
destroyed for
for expecting for expecting my plate no
hold it let me ram
let me rant for 15 seconds i got
destroyed
for just expecting the playstation to do
what it was advertised for
and the people was like hey i get it
codes in the chat you did you bought the
ps4 version attic you didn't buy the ps5
version
technically i didn't buy either cognito
did we going into that
like look at the end of the day i do
feel like look if you're going to buy
a game after it's come out on another
platform such as the ps4 to the ps5
if you're buying it after it's dropped
on the ps5 then you should have to pay
that extra ten dollars because you're
buying that ps5
but to me if you're buying it on the ps4
sony should just
grandfather you into that just because
first off
you're supporting their platform when a
lot
you know obviously a lot of people would
buy ps5 without if it's out by now but
a lot of like casual audience do not
support
day one console owners so it's like to
me i just felt like they were punishing
you
for upgrading like right i mean that's
what it sounds like it's
to me that i bought the deluxe edition
uh you know our boy went away dragons he
said he bought the 200 of the 200
version anybody who's paid the deluxe
version
and i'm not even going to trip if you
say i got to pay 10 10 extra dollars for
it that's cool if i you know
that's fine i'm not gonna you know trip
out on that
but i bought the deluxe edition that was
eighty dollars
and so then i gotta pay another twenty
that's fifty dollars that i'm giving the
sony for
old game that i already have and when
i'm looking at the competition
it's giving me for free and they're
giving enhancements on that and they're
not saying
oh well look you know what i'm saying we
uh we got these new controllers
and we want these new rumbles that we
got in these new controllers and the way
that they
and how accurate they feel we're going
to have to charge you another 10 20
that's not that's that that's not good
business and especially now when
are still not out of the out of the
copic situation and just
because the tone depth to the economics
that are actually purchasing this stuff
you got to look at the actual totality
and the numbers of
the ghost of sashimi game that's sold
right so once you look at that they say
how can we gouge those people because if
we can get
another 10 or 1 to 10 percent
of them to pay 10 uh for the same game
that they already purchased
that's already an install base that they
can actually dig
back into and receive more money from um
those practices uh are definitely
anti-consumer and what it does lead to
it leads to animaticity and bitterness
with that company because
i'm all i'm listening to you guys is
explaining of how much money you put up
front and then how much you're
asking to uh be put in again um
and you're looking at the competition
because it's only
uh smart for you to look around and not
have tunnel vision
you're looking at the competition and
the competition is saying oh you bought
said game yo
this game comes out on our newer
platform and if you have this game
already it's called smart delivery
people thought smart delivery was just a
catchphrase
and then realizing how smart it was and
how
smart it is and how smart you need to be
to partake in that situation because
you have to be some type of a weirdo to
believe that
it's smart to keep investing into the
same product that you've already
purchased
i want you to take that same mentality
every time you go to your refrigerator
anytime you put something inside your
refrigerator if you have to go and put
five dollars in your refrigerator
you will get rid of that refrigerator
and every time you got inside your car
and you say yo um i already paid my bill
my car is paid for i don't need to pay
anything else and they said oh wait a
second there's a steering wheel feet
what the hell are you talking about the
steering wheel you know what the crazy
thing is king
and k mega like when it comes to the
games we always we always
is like look like we need better quality
games on microsoft
and the reason we need that is because
the competition such as sony's making
high quality games
but to me i feel like you know i don't
when it comes to features and stuff like
that i feel like
that energy isn't returned like when you
bring up something like that they're
like well just because microsoft's doing
that doesn't mean everyone needs to do
that
and it's just like look like we want
everyone to do everything better like
not just games features we want the
whole nine yards like
we shouldn't demand one company to do
something better because the other
company does it better
and then when it's vice versa when it
comes to games we expect microsoft to
make better games
but then when it but but when
playstation's lacking on the features
and nintendo's lacking on the features
it's like it's always just like well you
know microsoft's doing that why should
everyone have to do that or
you know it's just nintendo and i'm just
like how about everyone improves you
know what i'm saying like
this is the thing that trips me out the
fellas is
the fact that the same people that will
cap for most of toshima for whatever
that sony's been doing
with their older titles here lately is
the same people that will
get mad and say ea they're charging you
extra for
ray tracing oh ea look at battlefield
there's no multi there's no single
player experience it's only just
multiplayer but then i guarantee you
when you you'll be quick to pay that 70
for the last of us two uh online only
game that's going to be coming out
so what's the difference so again if
you're going to keep that energy
you got to keep it for everything you're
absolutely right it just knows my mind
that
that so many people just just take a
narrative and then they run with it
and then they keep running into the same
wall but eventually the wall is gonna
keep was gonna win
you're gonna fall down because you just
kept putting it into the same wall you
know
it's crazy you know what this is
equivalent of people this is equivalent
of microsoft selling you gears of war
five and then
and then they're like oh when
microsoft's selling you backwards
compatible games
oh we need that five dollars for that
auto hdr
we need five dollars for that boost mode
you know what i'm saying like
it's just like just because the platform
does it naturally just like the ps5 does
the haptic
feedback naturally and the 3d all to add
naturally
does not mean that you should be sure
but you get what i'm saying
like does it oh you get what i'm saying
i was getting there right
i was saying that just because something
like that happens does not mean that you
should have to wait till it goes
and actually buy it but let me get these
super attached real quick because
because uh coat's in a long super chat
so i'm assuming he has some slander
so we gotta fight all the superman from
toto dope i just got my
iron lords hat thanks guys i love it
definitely appreciate it man
uh you know uh we definitely got some
good merchandise you have to think
keying david down there for all that
because
are we working on cool story new merch
roll out is coming cool story this this
is some shame on addicting i was against
the merchandise when it first brought us
i was like we ain't big enough to be
doing that
we can't we shouldn't be spending the
money and what's funny is
most the time i let the lords rock it
man i don't really care for the majority
of the stuff but
i did i pushed back hardcore for the
merchandise and i lost
but because i lost that particular thing
y'all win how come the shirts and
everything blew up
now it's just like i give king full
reigns oh he wants to do it it's fine
what he really hated was the fact that i
purchased 200 t-shirts
got them made got them done and gave
them all out for free yeah yeah was
doing it at e3
yeah well that that's that's the time
we're talking about
what the hell yo i mean the bottom line
because that was before
that i think the price we wasn't making
a [ __ ] yeah that was before the party
has brought in money so
that came out of our pockets well their
pockets i didn't come out of that but
yeah
but yeah that's that's when you're in a
position to invest in yourself you got
to believe in yourself and invest in
yourself and
like microsoft has been doing they have
been investing in them and you know
what's crazy
we saw people do like you know the q and
a things that e3 we saw people with our
shirts on
doing beautiful so we got a ten dollar
super chat from
optimus code unchained all right here we
go let me go and read this
if you bought a dvd and and that same
movie comes out on blu-ray should that
studio give
you the blu-ray for free did any of
y'all
not upgrade your movie collection from
dvd did they
give them to you for free so king can i
answer that please yes you can answer
that
yeah cole do you baby
you know seventy dollars do you baby
eighty dollars
i don't baby i don't ever never
ever do i ever pocket watch what you
choose to be okay for you
what you choose to be okay for you is
fantastic i'm speaking for the masses
say i'm speaking for the people that's
in my dm that's crying
i'm speaking for those individuals now a
lot of people didn't upgrade to that
blu-ray
from that dvd a lot of people saw it and
said no i'll buy the new movie when it
came out
same thing when you upgraded to a 4k uh
blu-ray player
and did you switch your your information
over there to get the next one
some companies gave you the the upgraded
version for free some people
didn't and and i don't know hold on hold
on because
you know um is this is this mentality
and this
narrative that feels that's what's good
for one is good for all what's good for
you is not good for everybody else
so if you feel that that you want to
equate it to that situation
that's good so then don't ever
ever ever let me see you complaining
with sony continue to ramrod you
with everything that they choose to do
because you
are choosing to accept it you guys are
paying 70
for games where the competition is not
forcing anyone to do
anything of that matter so if the
competition isn't
and sony's trying to push the industry
only for their game
does that benefit you or is it at your
detriment and when will you
wake up to see that you are being taken
advantage of you cannot
force a sip to realize that he's being a
sim
for someone that doesn't care for him
right and then also another point to
this is that
uh this is the reason why uh for that
strategy of what what
what he's talking about what code is
talking about shout out to code i
appreciate him uh when
my mom was in the hospital and he gave a
shout out man so i appreciate that
um uh but i do have to say this as well
is that
this is what brought competition this is
what made people say
nah i'm not gonna pay that two three
four five hundred dollars for this
blu-ray player
i'm just gonna go ahead and go to red
box i'm just gonna go ahead and go to
blockbuster
and then eventually netflix came around
and then they
when they was giving out dvds for a
service fee
people started jumping over and
clamoring over it so
that's that's that's what's going on
right now the old way of how sony
and gaming used to be is is fading
and now services and i said this i said
this
a couple of years back i said this back
on multiplayer back in when i was over
there
with uh porter rocking on z and all that
i was i was listening
what's coming up here is going to be
services
and and you know say it's going to be
services services
is going to be a new form of way to to
to to kind of counteract what mark cerny
and um amy henny both said in an article
basically talking about saying look
games are costing so much and also sean
lane said the same thing in this article
basically like gaming uh
we're at a position to where gaming is
now going up to if you want to make a
big
aaa experience it's going to be up to
like 200 million dollars
when when when mark cerny and amy henney
was bringing this up talking about
single-player experiences is that they
want
people to play their products and and
and be invested
we have to find another way to get
people involved into that
and what you see now is what xbox is
pushing forward
that's that's just evolution and you
know what's going to happen
there's going to be other companies
that's going to take that's going to
jump forward
if not if sony can't do this then sony's
in
big big trouble they had the opportunity
sony
struck blood first with when they
brought playstation now
the point of it is that they got greedy
and they didn't think about
the long term they always talk about the
acceptance of what was going on because
of the old way of how gaming was
it's all changed now the game has
evolved and now sony is looking
at everybody else already catched up if
not
going to surpass them when it comes to
the technology aspect of it
people can still keep talking about
these single-player experiences all they
want to
but if they keep costing 20 uh you know
uh 200 some million dollars
then you're going to see a lot less of
it the the the
flaw in the playstation now yeah they
struck first
the floor on the playstation now that it
was
it wasn't downloadable right they added
that
later so you had a perceived latency
and things it was more of like an
x-cloud
feel to it where that infrastructure
wasn't ready yet
so playstation now struggled the thought
was there
was too many generations ahead and
somebody looked at that that that flawed
philosophy
and said if we make it downloadable and
then later on we can revisit
that whole cloud-based infrastructure at
a at another point when we are
better that's the the azure cloud uh
situation
um we can actually be in position
to take advantage of that and i think
when they purchase guy kai
um their thoughts were so far ahead
they was trying to push the technology
forward and notice that it was
being held back by said technology and
that technology is old at this moment
that that's why they have uh enlisted
the help of microsoft to help them
with their uh you know cloud-based
situation
to get them into a position where they
can actually take advantage of their
vast library
and their great titles so i think
the the the planning stages are
happening
i think they're they're because you
notice that they have uh
local download on playstation now stuff
now
um it should be more robust it should be
on every title and not limited titles
right um but i think they they're
revisiting the strategy
when it comes to that playstation now
because they do have an
install base and they would love to take
advantage of it and i think they're
they're trying to explore ways to keep
it active and to get it better
first thing i want to say is let me
address what
uh what colt said um i don't think
that's even a fair statement to even
like compare it to because to me dvds
was way before blue rays and you know
you you can
we're talking about games on like a
single thing like
to me that's different hardware that's a
different
data storage like that's not the same
like
for the most part and i think for every
part
you can't upgrade a dvd to a blu-ray
with an update
like like so to me i don't feel like
that's a fair comparison code like
like you can't i just didn't pay it any
money yeah but you know we
still got to talk about that no i don't
mean i answered it but
yeah i just didn't pay it any mind
because it was just
you know um it's it's you swinging at
the air for no reason you're not gonna
make contact with something that makes
no sense if two people stand in the way
and you're talking to somebody who's
making no sense
and from a distance you're just going to
see two people that's making no sense
talking
i refuse to engage in conversations that
don't make any sense it didn't make any
sense yeah no
and then on top of that the fact of it
is if sony was doing exactly what
xbox was doing with this everybody would
be praising this even
i we would all on this panel would have
to praise this and one i would have a
microsoft playstation now
right right right right so i mean
that's the difference is that to me it's
that look you can swing and defenses all
you want to
logic tells you that sony since they
made
they made the first move going in this
direction they should
they should have they should have had
all their ducks in a row and prepared to
take the hit
but then eventually been paying the
dividends just think about what
playstation would have been right now if
they get if they
went this same way that xbox is doing
back then
and now since everybody's internet most
likely you start well not everybody but
most people's internet has catched up
things that this ancient playstation
would be totally dominant and xbox would
be
in deep trouble in the sense you know so
that's
that's just how this ball rolls so yeah
no i totally agree king is absolutely
friendly
let me address some stuff in the chat
look code can come in here you can give
his own opinion no one got to attack the
man in the chat
uh code always in here every week given
his opinion
sure some of them are out of this world
opinions
but he is in here always wanting to give
some kind of feedback
sure some feedback is out of this world
so try to keep it a little bit
respectful in that chat with him
so let let me um let me please
he's super chatted ll so let me
let me get these uh super chats we got a
two dollar trip from king one supreme co
code cool king you should go on
heartache show with code
uh then we got a uh five dollar strip
from joe that's
that's not something that you're gonna
catch me doing i'm regal
i don't do that yeah you really don't
see king on too many shows at all i go i
go on shows
where i support the platform for certain
things certain things i just don't
you don't you don't hear me curse yeah
you don't hear a lot at the end of the
day
like if it doesn't make sense for the
brand if my children can't watch it you
won't see me on it
yeah and then we got five dollars from
gerald mack at this point
the cat for playstation is pure survival
mode
i refuse to believe that they're blind
loathe he doesn't allow them to see
the uh vows survival mode look at
i don't even know how to take that are
you saying that they're capping for
playstations pure survival mode
because i would kind of agree with you a
little bit because i feel like no matter
what he's doing is
the playstation dudes is in survival so
they're grasping at straws
you know you know if you throw somebody
over a ship they're gonna grab anything
to float with
to stay alive i feel that i understand
that
and it's absolutely the truth they will
grasp at anything to hold on to it until
they can get that triple a bang and it
actually hits to justify their purchase
listen a lot of people purchase that
playstation 5 above market value and
they're trying to justify their purchase
at any point in time
and i agree with you you should feel
like nobody wants to pick a loser nobody
wants to pick anything that's
that doesn't show them their value
immediately they're having a hard time
saying why are these xbox dudes so happy
and there's no first party games there's
just none of that stuff we have this
stuff we
we are happier than you are why it is so
happy why they're championing this stuff
because
we see value in our purchase the reason
why you're looking over and you have the
time to do so is because you do not see
value in your purchase
remember those lists remember last year
yeah remember the list all those
games yeah we haven't seen no lists yeah
like
what's crazy
let me just go we got the five dollars
to protect from optimus code he just put
loll
look man you know how we are code
if you are saying off the wall [ __ ] that
makes no
sense we are going to give you straight
facts and shoot that down man i'm sorry
that you tried to climb the ladder
uh uh uh and then we just we we what's
that
what's that game pick the letter we
didn't even kick the ladder we let you
come up on top of the ladder
and we just pushed you back down like
you're gonna have to come at us with a
little bit more better logic to me than
that but now talk to me when god will
come back
so let's go ahead and move on uh you
know i think we butchered that to death
the coalition uh obviously they
they i personally feel like they they
put the xbox brand on their back the
whole xbox one generation
and you know clearly they're taking a
little bit of a break in terms of gears
but it looks like
since they have their hands on the
unroll engine they're going
to go ahead and make a different type of
game uh
we don't know what it is we don't know
the scale it's going to be look it is
going to be on a smaller scale than
gears
but that can mean anything because gears
is a huge game
so what i want to ask you guys is i
think we can all agree that we want
their best talent at the end of the day
regardless how we feel about 343 and
halo infinite
uh maybe not necessarily now but back
then that's still some of their best
talent
uh coalition still some of their best
talent we've always stated that we want
them to make
more different types than just the gears
and the halos
do you think it's an issue that they're
not going to finish that trilogy before
they start something new
or do you think that you know because i
feel like with this we might not see a
gear six to like
20 26 20 25. how do you guys feel about
this i'm going to start with k mega
uh you know i feel fine about that and
i've i've said that i've been on the
record of saying that look let
gears take a break keep building on what
they're doing with gears
with gears fives multiplayer i mean the
more and more and then also just
if if they feel i could bring more dlc
because
hive busters was absolutely amazing for
people who have not played hive busters
i'm telling you it's not that long
of a game but it is visually one of the
best looking games that you can see
this gin hands down and you know what
okay i gotta interrupt you real quick
i have to bring this up here every time
anyone brings up high busters
when when gears 5's five first came out
what's the number one critique
man this is a good game but it's just
gears more gears like
we want something different but then
when gears high busters come out
they're saying people was like high
busters this fire hey uh
okay mega hey king would it be fair to
say that high buster's more like gears
than than gears 5 is
yeah that just blows my mind like
no one's consistent you go ahead and
continue okay megan
i just had to bring that up i don't know
i just i just love the the direction of
the doing what they did and of course
you know
um of course you know with the whole
situation that where people watching uh
uh you know the he-man or the masters of
the universe and then you know people
get upset because of support characters
getting some love
i love the fact that that's what they
were doing with with gears that's what i
want them to do with halo
is give these support characters a lot
more love
and even though this was a small as a
small short entry
and then also when you look at gears
tactics which wasn't a small entry but
still a really good game just a
different type of genre game
um that that's that's build
that that that character building is
that is something that we need
but again if they're going to do
something which i've been thinking that
maybe this could be
that they might be trying to do that
that shanghai nights uh
or something of that nature i am all for
that
i'm not never against anybody that wants
to do something different
uh within within whatever that they
normally do
i just i'm not one of the good type to
to
to be like with three four three five
well four three needs to be some if 343
wants to just do nothing and
just stick with halo without them being
forced to it if they're forced to do it
that's different if they're not forced
not all they want to do is halo
to let them do that if the coalition is
got the opportunity to want to do
something different
then let them do that i have no problem
with that so yeah i think the gears need
to take a break
because this is the time now where xbox
is getting all the eggs in the in the
basket
and it's going to have plenty of other
content to throw in between
they didn't have that luxury last gen
and
this game now getting going forward and
especially with the stuff with game pads
there's plenty of content that will wet
the palette until another gears come out
and actually what you want to do is wait
that's why i'm really i'm really excited
about what they're going to what turn 10
is going to do with forza uh
seven uh is because of the fact that
they uh
is it for success motorsport um with
fortune motorsport because they're
taking
enough time to build and then they're
letting everything else
just do their thing so yeah i think that
uh
i wouldn't be mad about it at all if you
want to do something different that's
fine
i commended for it that's what's up so
first off let me uh i switched the
layout a little bit i want the
the chats opinion what do you guys think
look better this one or the one that's
currently using
let's go ahead and get this uh super
chat real quick before uh king
uh speaks s spits the the the
book of x because i have a philly
uh you know i got a five dollar super
chat from marvin ginyard
i i think i got that i don't know sean
is for uh forgetting that microsoft is
operating off a trillion
dollar budget substantially only
affecting those below them
definitely understand that man all right
so king
how do you feel about whether or not
they might not be making gears
right now or are they making gears in a
few years from now
well um like you stated they uh put
uh the xbox brand on their back them and
turned 10.
um you know it was really gears in the
forza franchise before the horizon
you know and then forza and gears
actually
keeping them afloat uh you know halo 5
didn't hit like how everybody expected
it to hit
so 343 was kind of looked at with the
snide eye
and they have more to prove than uh
those two
studios turned 10 uh playgrounds or
the coalition you know you felt that
those three studios
um actually did more than 343
when it came to holding the xbox brand
afloat
so uh you get some form of clout right
gorilla games held uh
sony up for a long period of time and
they were given carl blanche under shawn
laden to
uh pursue a title that they felt very
passionately about and
you got horizon without sean's foresight
and uh guerrilla games actually working
uh to push that title forward with you
know
because they were there at the forefront
for every sony uh
launch and supporting them and fixing
stuff with killzone
uh they actually gave them
the ability to make something that they
were passionate about and you got
horizon and horizon is
a fantastic title that we were skeptical
about in the beginning because we felt
that our first person studio
shooter studio shouldn't be making a
third person game and
we didn't know what it would happen you
know and what it would be for some
people it hits for some people who
didn't hit but
overall the majority of people loved the
title and
they made a character that is synonymous
with a lot of their iconic characters in
a stable
um i believe that the coalition should
be
afforded the same luxury i believe that
they have uh done
the same if not um more so than
um gorilla games as far as the xbox
brand goes
and they should be given the ability and
they should be given the budget to make
either a large site or a small title
to to show what they can do and
diversify
their portfolio to show that their value
to microsoft isn't just gear so when you
do walk into the studio
and you do hear the name the coalition
you do see different titles that pop up
and they can show the versatility within
all the developers that they do
have making their games you know all the
coders everybody is working hard they
want to show diversity because i'm
pretty sure to get it around
the board oh the coalition the gears
team so you don't want to be just known
as a one-trick pony you want to be known
as a diverse uh studio um
with that being said uh i don't care how
long it takes for him to do another
gears game
um i think right now as we've been
talking about the diversity inside game
pass knowing that all the games is day
and date inside game pass
uh you need that space to breathe
okay megan said that the next or frozen
forza motorsports
has them peaked and intrigued because
it's they're taking a break off to give
you
more and and to really bite down and it
doesn't feel like a madden type of
situation
where every year is just a minor update
on mitre iteration
that you don't really get that chance to
breathe in between titles
to actually give you everything that you
want to put in because
we've noticed and we found out through
ea
that these madden titles don't get the
full breadth
of all the stuff that's on the board and
stuff has to be cut down
into order to make deadlines artificial
deadlines
the game pass structure takes away that
artificial game
that uh that artificial deadline it
removes it from the individuals
now there's an artificial deadline for
halo but you notice that was shattered
when it didn't reach expectations
because they said
whenever it does drop it will be in game
pass and we want a good
title to a great title instead of a
mediocre title so i think game pass
gives them comp wants to do so
and i think the coalition is hitting at
the right time and i and i
and i they earned it they earned
everything that they get
so they should be allowed the car blocks
to make a title and i think it's going
to be fantastic regardless of what
because i think they work is great
oh yeah i do i i want to kind of throw
something in here too on top of that
okay so like you just mentioned
uh madden and i'm going to throw nba 2k
into this
as well like i wonder if what ubisoft is
doing with
assassin's creed um what is it called
infinite that's going to be coming up
i wonder if it if that turns out to be
pretty successful
will madden and nba 2k do one of these
things where they take the time
and take a maybe two year hiatus kind of
like what battlefield does two three
year hiatus
kind of give uh entry every every year
like i mean you get an
update for those two three years but
then they come with a more dominant
product
and they still can throw everything else
that they can still make their money off
of
i think that that would be more
beneficial because i i feel you like
i i love i get mad every year i've been
getting mad
every year ever since 19 19 1994.
so but for this time this this first
time
i'm i might i might not pull the trigger
because i stopped purchasing
yeah you know i still got that video of
you and tim you know
oh yeah yeah yeah so so it's so to me
it's kind of like
you know what i i get this i get this
but then what i'm looking at while
there's all the benefits of what
what we're seeing from from from from
game pass game pass has kind of changed
and evolved my whole thought process
about how gaming is in the first place
and i'm like you know what i don't care
about games and services
and some people may think they're so
afraid of it i think that that would be
the best strategy
to do if not at least make it a free to
play yeah yeah with a sports title
that you know that every year they're
going to be doing this if you can do if
you could go free to play or if you can
go and do
what uh and do with like what assassin's
creed is thinking about what yourself
would be okay
so i think it'd be impossible the only
reason why that won't happen is because
madden has a monopoly
on the nfl uh license right so
and having a monopoly you get to dictate
because you'd only stop you the only
shop in town
that's like if you you know you're the
only person that sells hamburgers
everybody must see you
if they want to eat that meat pause
right so
madden knows what it has so madden is
going to constantly go to the well in
the matter that it does and it gives
minor iterations and removes stuff that
you love like
you will they remove something that you
love me like man
i i used to love that you know the the
front line blocking how you can control
that and you can just
actually make a hole here but they
changed it with something else and they
did they took away the cone and
when when they started changing right
yeah to make senseless changings
i i left that was it for me um so
at the same time i understand your
frustration but i'm from from a business
aspect
if they had competition it would force
change
right it won't they don't have
competition so
change will not happen because change
doesn't need to happen
i think that first off uh let me go
ahead and get these super chats real
quick before they get too
too out of out of control we got a two
dollar street shop from everborn saga
what's
what's good players uh definitely ever
yeah i'll be on real
real this week we got to talk about that
uh masters of the universe
yeah yeah exactly exactly you must go
show support to everborn
get out there
is what needs to be done and what you
like seeing
and he you know i've always been one of
the biggest people
you know support people that are good
because i don't want to i don't want to
build people for
bad expectations if that makes sense to
you like
he's good content go support him man go
support k
mega too great podcast especially i'll
meet you know me and cog
especially we'd be talking to xbox live
parties it'll be like man came echo he's
streaming them
that that fight night thing man you know
gotta go
there and support that man we got a two
dollar stream hey megatron came in there
and dusted us in old school street
fighters
street fighter uh he beat my ass he beat
lemon
he beat he beat yo me i was like what
did he was just laughing the whole time
it was it was kind of like how i did you
in naruto
and then watch out now yeah now i i got
to get some revenge on naruto
listen some killer instincts and you
know
and i ain't messing with you and none of
that stuff okay you come in you're come
into my kingdom i'm not coming in yours
so we got a two dollar shipment from
michael aka benson's finest shout out to
king salute bro
xbox for life and then we got a five
dollar stream from optimus code
unchained
king is spot on about coalition making
what's passionate to them
he finally said something that's true
but god bless thank you listen more you
hear more
here's how i feel about it i don't mind
them doing it if they want to do it then
do it
to me i would actually prefer them to
finish gear six because i'm really
invested into that story at this point
but i understand you know maybe it's
better for the brand if we see what they
can make that's not gears
even if it's a smaller project and then
uh you know gear six
could be better because now they know
that system a little bit better that
engine a little bit better
so when they do make gear six you get a
better product but you saw the alpha
that went out
yeah but i'm greedy i want my [ __ ] now i
don't wanna i
all up on this stuff right now but i
don't got access to it so you know what
they
look at what they did with ford they
still have they could still bring
something out off of unreal engine 4
and look at what they did with hive
busters like they can still
get more juice out of that engine so i
they're they're mad they remind me of
turn 10. they're masters at their craft
at what they do man
yeah it's just it's just these dudes
these
developers need to gain uh the mastery
of these new hardwares
they don't want the same old because
what i've noticed that
um i don't everybody talks about they
see this generational leap i don't
you know um you're gonna tell me that
these games they they haven't reached
their peak yet
so you know the ratchet and clank it
looked great go back and see ratchet and
clank when it launched on the
playstation 4. that looked great too
you know so it's these are marginable uh
increments going forward you have more
fur shading here
you have this and you have that we won't
really see what these systems is capable
of until mid-june when we hit the mid
gym when we start to get those titles
that are actually uh uh you know all the
development tools
they're still telling you monthly if not
weekly
new development tools are being released
for both
consoles because both consoles are
essentially the same they're smaller
things that's inside of them
that differentiates between the two but
new tools are being released for these
guys we haven't seen an unreal engine 5
game yet you know so in the wild we've
just seen
demos we've seen uh them use assets and
stuff like that so we have
uh dreams of this stuff going forward
but we actually
need to see them going forward so when
it you know we got you here
you're crazy we're nuts just then but um
when when we
actually see the unreal engine 5 in all
its glory then you start to see the true
mastery of these systems because
what these systems really do is
calculate at a high rate
and they deliver fast information but
they don't need to use all the computing
power of the last consoles
because the tool sets are made in the
sense that you will get
all of that fidelity at a lower impact
to the gpu and the cpu so
you're going to start seeing ai done in
different areas you're going
to see car physics in different things
it's going to change the way that we
play but we're just not at that space
yet
we're going to get there but these games
that we've seen so far
it's still just last gen games with the
upgrade refresh i agree and
you know we've got a two dollar spirit
from shrimp kingdom put gears to sleep
please
the series has insomniac to me actually
i actually really
dig where the gears franchise is right
now i know i'm the minority in this but
like i really enjoyed the story they're
telling with kate the only
issue i had with gears 5 was the sand
area that's all like
i felt like act one was good you didn't
love it you didn't like the santa
i did not like the sand area i think you
could have literally took that
besides the boss at the end with the the
rocket thing you could took that whole
thing
and just put it out of the game i'll
have been fine but i really enjoyed the
first act i enjoyed the second act
it's like like it's like like the third
act was horrible but
compared to the second act with the snow
it was
far lacking and then i really enjoyed
act four like
i don't understand when we get this
concept that gears 5 was a
was even an average game i felt like it
was a great game
i actually felt like it it was a couple
points shy of where i
personally would have liked to have been
in the metacritic score i think it
deserved like an 87.88 but that is what
it is medicare scores not everything
i agree with you but you know i just
enjoyed where they're going with it and
i'd be really
disappointed to me i wanted to see that
conclusion and that was just
me i understand i'm not everyone and i
understand people want newer things from
these companies like i said it's their
best
it's it's the best studios that they
have maybe they should make something
new
but let's go on to our last topic man
before we get let's get this five
dollars
from godzilla i butchered your name man
i don't think i did but we're gonna say
i did
y'all need to make a four hour long song
that plays on starting screen screen
always popping my head when i listen to
it especially
surround uh surround sound matt uh shout
out to uh
you know matt keep forgetting his name
who did that one again alice
dallas yeah there is shout out to dallas
you guys need to go check him out you
know if you need any kind of stuff like
that made
he obviously we we we promote every
sunday at 1 pm definitely go check out
the iron lords podcast every sunday at
1pm
we promo it all the time at the uh
starting soon screen
you definitely need to go check that out
but let's talk about
i feel like is the highlight of this
topic
we have death's door coming out it's
like an 86 87 meter credit cause
playstation people love talking about
that metacritic score
and boy we got you some metacritic
scores like
death door 8687 i don't know where it is
now and it's looking like flight
similarly gonna be a 90-plus game
we probably going to get a for a horizon
zero and
forza horizon 5 90 plus game
i would say halo is going to be in the
mid 80s uh depending on how that story
hits it that story hits
i wouldn't be surprised if that's a
90-plus game but that story is
what really is the question mark the
variable there what i want to ask you
guys
and i think that you know this is
something that
a lot of people have fear with when it
comes to game pass is
that game pass filler now i'm not gonna
say every game in game pass is
phenomenal
but i'm saying that in terms of what the
first party is doing in their
in their timed exclusives that they have
because i assume death story gonna come
to all platforms eventually i'm seeing a
high quality
come out of that that that wall and i
don't think you can
fairly say that you know i think
microsoft has successfully
cut that 69 mega quick store out of
their slate
i think it's been there for a while you
know i feel like for a while we've
gotten pretty high quality stuff
last year wasteland three was like an 86
87.
there's been a lot of good games coming
out of that platform so
i want to ask you guys is do you think
that with these
you know what these highly rated games
coming out of
game pass do you think that's gonna
eventually lead to you know
the subscription service leaving that
you know oh game pass only has
bad games in it or you know lowly rated
games because to me i see
especially going into the future you
fable you know about
i see none of those being low rated
games whatsoever
i see high quality i feel like now
the longer time goes on we're gonna see
more high quality games and
game pass is going to be that place that
you could go just to play the greatest
games in the platform
king what's your thoughts on this um
i i don't really pay attention to
metacritics uh
because it's like asking somebody to
chew my food for me
so um what i might find um
really good somebody else may hate like
i really like crackdown because
that's how crackdown is for me i like
you know going in
to nooks and crannies i actually really
wish they would put all their time that
they put into that multiplayer into that
single player and i thought that crack
down
crackdown single play was so good it was
awesome
it was the music everything yeah yeah i
was having such a great time with it
so um a lot of times i'm at diameter
really opposed to whatever metacritic
says you know even for the playstation
or
or for nintendo and stuff like that i i
don't really care for it
um but to your point and you know for
the people that do care for it
uh i think game pass has shown you right
now i think if you go through game pass
you go game by game
and you start looking at the metacritic
source for each game
you're gonna notice that the average is
probably like an 80 all the way through
and i'm being very generous you know
with that 80 because it's probably
higher than that
um and i and i say this to say game pass
is is not going to be the place where uh
low rated games live and and is
permeated with low rated games
the studios that are purchased and the
level of talent
uh explains that it will water will
reach its level
water will actually rise to where it's
supposed to be
so if you have that much talent given
enough time
then before i don't think they had the
time
and i don't think they had enough
studios to give them that time to make
these games and polish these games in a
manner that they needed to be
because they were always chasing the
dragon which sony
had a uh a longer uh tooth in the game
don't forget sony were growing to the
space that they were they didn't have
games that can challenge
nintendo games at that period of time
when they were growing into that space
so what did they do they they leveraged
their diversity they leveraged their
storage capacity they leveraged
different things to gain a foothold in
that space
and they gave their titles time to
breathe you know uncharted didn't start
off fantastic uncharted got to fantastic
by them reinvesting into those titles so
microsoft is doing the same thing what
y'all think is
i think uh xbox and playstation came out
at the same
time they didn't playstation is uh a
older stronger brand because it came out
before and it had that ability to
grow into that space microsoft is
actually growing into that space
phil dominance maximiser really is
spencer
rain will be known as the rain
that solidified microsoft footing
into this this position and when they
become
the absolute market leader then you will
understand
who did that for you and why it happened
because it was that dude's vision that
came from the bottom of the company
to raise to the highest level in that
company that cared about that company
remember that same thing when you look
over at jim dance moves ryan
and sean is on the outside looking in
because sean
raised playstation to where it was those
glory days
in playstation was under sean sean grew
up in that company
sean made that company to what it was so
microsoft will definitely have those
titles those bangers they're going to
come they will be there but you needed
time to get
there i think they have time the money
and the developers
to start averaging 90s inside
uh that metacritic for those people that
care about that stuff
yeah so so how you feel about this game
here because i know like
you know i'm with king i don't really
care too much about the metacritic score
thing but
i do feel like in terms of the industry
a lot of people do
and i think that you know i don't think
people go to like gamestop and
oh i don't know if i buy this call of
duty let me see what the metacritic
score is
but i do feel like you know in terms of
you know the reviewers that do it the
industry that does it the publishers
that does it the reviewing sites like
ign gamespot that do it
i feel like that in terms of the
hardcore casual audience
they do have their ear to that pulse and
how do you feel about this um
okay yeah no i was trying to look for
something that i was that i post in the
uh grg uh dm i can't find it right now
but it was it was basically showing
the chart of how many game pass games
has been available uh and how many
they're going to be leaving and how many
that's gone so it was like
up to almost 500 games and the rating
and i believe i posted it on twitter
about maybe almost a couple of weeks
maybe a month ago or so
that they have way more
higher rated games than they do the
games that are
60 plus um so everything that that was
just stated before was was absolutely
correct the thing
to me is um the importance
of of diversity variety this is what
made
the 360 great as it was
variety is what made the playstation as
great as it was
once you get to a point to where you
just only have to lean on
your greatest games it becomes stale
it's just no different than anything
from movies from you know music
anything else it's just kind of like how
i look at the rap game now
and i'm listening to every there's a
little something everywhere a little
baby little oozy little whatever and
it's all sounds the same
there's very little variety in the music
that i used to that
and i still love hip-hop but it's just
not the same to me
and the more and more that you have
people that that that
they they'll love god awards they love
the ratchet and clanks they love
the horizon zero dawns but by the time
that you get to horizon zero down
four and and then you got god of war
how many and ratchet clank how many and
these get it's going to get to a point
where people are going to start looking
and saying
i need to start getting my variety from
somewhere else
and that's why when you have these rated
these low-rated games or whatever that
you know microsoft
you know that was already you know king
david already said that eloquently he
said that correctly
they were they were behind the a ball
they were just trying to catch up
phil spencer and my and from me
i love jack trent from playstation i
thought that that
that dude had the swag he had he gave
playstation
everything that that's why i was that
made me a diehard place they should do
back in those days once jack trenton
left
it kind of changed but they still kept
that diversity
now you're starting to see it creep that
they're more about the dollar than they
are about their diversity
and what i see phil spencer is is in
that same realm as jack trent
has a different type of swag got that
hunger got something different
about him that that is needed for the
xbox brand
and and to revitalize the xbox brand to
the weight to its greatness of the 360
is having diverse games and
nine times out of ten the casual market
do not care about
metacritic scores they care about what
games give them the most fun
and that is the most important thing all
you know in all like when people go and
looking
i'm thinking like uh wet for instance
that was on the 360.
loved wit that game had a horrible
rating
but that game was still fun to a lot of
people i believe that uh
dante's inferno didn't get a great
rating but a lot of people love dante's
inferno
those type of games uh you know those
those double
a nd type of titles those are what
is those means the missing component in
order to get people to
invest into your your platform it's the
aaa bankers are always going to bring
it's going to it's going to attract
but it's the overall diversity that's
what's that gets people to say oh man
i remember this game i remember that
game this game like um
uh the ubisoft game that kind of got
that discontinued it came back
was from the movie i can't figure the
name of it right now uh it was a it was
a
a beat em up like uh dragon like like uh
ah like double dragon what was that uh
scott pilgrim scotland
yeah yeah yeah scott pilgrim that game
like people was clamoring about that if
that game is not something that
would sell a console but it's something
that would give people to be invested if
that was an exclusive
there's no different than then like you
look at this game right here i'm i just
booted it up because
um you know i got to give a shout out to
jay bash he sit there and hook me up
with it with this door so i'm like i
told him i was going to play it but i
was playing
um uh flight simulator mostly all day
today so
i i just i just downloaded that game
uh which one this door no um flight
simulator oh yeah man
i was i was all into training man it
felt made me feel like i was like i was
at work
i ain't never been to uh to king's part
of the
part of the country i might have to fly
over there with the
but that's the thing to me is that xbox
is giving something that's
more valuable than just a rating and
that is the diversity
that is the most important thing for any
gamer out there that's why i still
clamoring for more fighters
for more hack and slash because uh and
for
if it's more jrpgs xbox is now seeing to
go into that direction and bring more of
that variety
while playstation seems to be wanted to
try to hold on to
to what was great at one particular time
or what is great for them
at this particular time and kind of push
away
those games that like gravity rush and
the
the last guardian and things like that
which i feel that that's a mistake
overall so the ratings
the metacritic thing it doesn't bother
me whatsoever either i think that that's
overrated
yeah and i definitely understand that so
let's let's get
uh let's read this super chat we gotta
find out this is
interesting i actually have people
tweeting me this live i guess this was
just announced that
cr five dollars from christopher uh
jesser
uh i definitely we will be wrong past
that uh
we got a company ceo uh what's
what's what's the ceo's name again i
always butcher his name
saladia santiago yeah he said he made
the claim during the company's fourth
quarter earnings call on tuesday
the xbox series s and x is the fastest
selling
xbox consoles of course yeah i don't
think people realize how
how how little man is selling more than
people think
right right it is you think that i think
they built more little mans too
well the thing of it is is that when i
when i got little man
uh which was just about what a month and
a half ago
um for my wife um
which my wife is not a gamer that should
tell you something right there
um because she wants to play flight
simulator right
you don't even care about like gaming
like that but she loves she wanted to
play fight simulator
but when i was there at the store there
was so many people that was in there
to get uh xbox series x because they
want the bet the biggest and best but
then they said well we still have
this many series s's available then
there were some people that was like nah
man you got to let me know when you come
with a with a xbox series x
but there were some people was like well
what's the difference and then the
people was pretty accurate about
you know the serious ass and what they
could do and so there was people that
was buying them
so that and and so what
some of those people will do is that
they'll get it and then they'll then
they'll probably trade up
to get a series x but to get into the
to get the gateway to the next gen with
a 399 dollar
console well not even 399 i'm sorry it's
300
uh with taxes 327 dollars and if you add
a two year warranty
it's 257 i mean 357 so
you're winning you're winning regardless
so of course it's gonna it's going to
sell it's just like what i said earlier
the
the the biggest thing with it is this if
if you're purchasing an xbox series x
and you you plug it into your television
and it's not hitting all those boxes
because
this box is in the back right those
green boxes check marks all right
if you're joining gonna hit those check
marks then don't waste your money
absolutely hit xbox series s
get a little man little man gonna check
off all those boxes
so they have more 120 frames per second
games than the competition
little man is actually punching above
his weight
and weigh about his weight when these
tool sets start to hit because i have a
lot of dudes i mean i have a little man
i actually got to pick up another one
actually i got to pick up two more but
um
because i have a television that's
downstairs uh i happen to
unfortunately pick up the last great the
greatest
1080p television the last one made by
sharp
you know it's quad color it's greatest
but it's not a 4k television so
why the hell would i put an xbox series
exactly i will put little man on it and
little man will run
rings around that television and that
that's what he's made for
so um people got to understand their
circumstances
and then look at their finances and
their finances
will dictate exactly where their
motivation should rise
right you know don't try to keep up with
the joneses right of course
that's what fits your narrative stop
worrying about everybody else's
right and that's the whole point of with
with like okay you know
i'm i'm an xbox-centric gamer you know i
mean but i have playstation i have
nintendo i have that but
but with certain things it's like i mean
if i if i'm not going to get if i'm not
going to spend
all the time and effort on uh
on on my playstation then i'll get the
most affordable playstation yeah that
that's that's
that's what i'm that's what i was
looking for because once i i was looking
for the
disc list because i'm not afraid of of
uh
you know of not having a disc i mean
because i i'd rather
purchase my games download than have
than have a physical copy it's just less
clutter for me
but it's just that just to follow like
with the playstation i have the
playstation uh
slim i'm absolutely cool with it it's
it's still a little powerhouse for what
it does
it show god award it absolutely
fantastic and so for
my television like you know with
samsung's they don't have
every port being 4k so i'm like
well what's the point of me getting a
pro if unless i have to keep
interchanging and switching you know i'm
saying so i just might as well just go
ahead and get the slim so and i and i've
been content with it so it's it's fine
so
you're right everybody has to be within
their means uh but that's the one reason
it's like it's just the same reason like
i said earlier is that why playstation
gamers were over here making the point
of why people would buy the slim
is the same reason why people are going
to buy the series s
yeah and it's like when it comes to you
know the exclusive stuff like
i've always felt like microsoft now
they're not
under time for restraints that they used
to be under like
yeah when when 343 pops in but like yo
we need time more time for this
expansion on halo infinite
or coalition pops in like we need more
time for gear six
they're like oh we got a valve coming
out that year we got fable coming out
that year like
okay you could you can move yours
because we was probably gonna move your
game anyway
so like we can't have these games coming
out too much like i honestly feel like
microsoft
is going to be in the scenarios because
now
we have all of bethesda's studios and
obviously they're going to buy more
studios they've already
say they're buying more studios we all
the original studios the 15 original
studios
they all have multiple teams we're going
to have scenarios where microsoft is
going to have fully blown
aaa titles done and be like yo we can't
we can't let you eat other people's
games like okay let's move you back into
2023
2024 like because the game's done
you could go ahead take a little bit of
time to make sure they do a little bit
stuff that you guys wanted to do
because we got plenty to come out in
this time frame because
back in the day it used to be when 343
or coalition was like we need more time
they're like the only game coming out
this year fam like
we can't really give you that much time
but now it's not that case and
i feel like you're going to see a lot
more high-quality studio games and not
necessarily triple-a
but you're going to see high-quality
double-a games where it makes it feel
like it's triple-a because
they had the correct amount of time and
money to invest into that brand
and i i think we're gonna get that but
you know uh go ahead and uh get these
super chats
i'm gonna read these super chats get get
get these people out here man
we got they busy man they busy so uh we
we got a two dollar super stream for
007 i definitely know that dude's
important
but i don't know how to pronounce it can
we have a akira
video game by kojima i'm sure one of you
know that dude's name
oh
um akira from kojima no
this is the assistant no all right no uh
let's have a kira made by the people
that make naruto
um i i think they would be more or arc
systems yeah
yeah are people making they're making a
a my hero academic you know
yeah they're making a demon slayer game
and the people that's making uh uh the
people that you just said okay mega
they're making a my hero game
right and they're making a dungeon a
dungeon fighter too that's what i always
like
to be coming in i want studios that
actually
make anime games uh that stay
faithful to the anime i don't know a no
please
keep my gmo hell away from that then we
got a three dollar strip trap from
emerald a1
if xbox can finally get missed walker
it's over i'd
100 agree with you i'm a huge fan of
miss walker i love lost all to say i
love
blue dragon i would love for them to buy
that studio but
i don't think you got to be wanted to be
purchased too we got a ten dollar stream
track from gamer by choice
just showing supports to the lords and k
mega great show guys keep it up
megatron was feeding you that smoke on
street fighter man
he was giving it to him i heard he was
feeding you that smoke man
people don't want it people don't want
to stay in a lane
about their pockets and want to be in
king and lemons of the world but
but we work hard to play harder tco
is okay man i used to have a tcl tv
i was shamed by this man king david down
here on the bottom screen
over and over again you can't do that
and i didn't care about the shaming
you know when i cared about when i was
like maybe i need to step it up
i was playing gears 5 and i've told the
story a couple times i was playing
five of kid smooth he had an xbox one x
and i had an xbox one s
and it was loading the game quicker on
as kids moves
so there were scenarios where literally
they would have to keep me alive he
would have to keep me alive while i'm
loading in
because it's already loaded and
completely on kit smooth
and i'm filling the controller vibrating
i'm on a black screen
and i'm feeling the controller vibrating
because i'm being attacked
it can't it was very frustrating and
ever since then i'm like
i'm not getting no xbox series s i'm not
getting no xbox series s2
it's always the x because i'm never
having a scenario like that ever happen
again
but you know first off uh
yeah yeah man no i got a q90r right and
so like just like i was making the point
about like well you know
i stay within my means i don't try to
come out and boast and say that i get
this and get that because it's just
that's just i ain't got the bread like
that to be good but
you know what i'm saying but i'm proud
of my tv but i was saying once i give me
a playstation 5 is when i upgrade my
television because i got to get
more ports i can't stand the fact of
just having just one point on assembly
and i'm not going to give me an lg i'll
get a lg for my wife
um she's got an lg in there in the front
room now but if i
uh upgrade to the lg the the main one
where everybody
uh promotes that's for her because she
watched television i'm a gamer i'd just
rather be on my samsung
but my wife's mom uh invested into a uh
a tia a teach a tlc or whatever
yeah and uh i said look i i'm not sure
if you want to get that
you may want to get something else and
then some you know she was about
oh that price is right blah blah blah so
then uh
about eight months later she had this
this this black screen
pop up on the side and it would go away
and i was like listen
you get you get what you pay for i told
my mom cause she was looking at
the same type of television i had to
tell her about it so then she got her
samsung too now she's
she's oh she's fine so you can't
listen i get it people have budgets
but you got at least budget to get the
right tyler televisions i say samsung
and lg's are the best way to go
sony's are good televisions too as well
i got i got a sony in in the uh in the
bedroom and then i got a sony in the
other spare room they just got to do
their research but you got to do your
research
yeah just with anything you know you
just don't go out and you know just go
purchase off
the road especially if it's a
life-changing things
like you know you you do your research
when you buy a house you buy you do your
research
when you buy a car um televisions are
the same
people because you're doing research
asking what what a lemon law is on
facebook six months later
and
you're doing this is your media hub this
is yeah yeah could you imagine
during the whole pandemic you sitting
there with some bargain basement
television and you can't go outside
and you're sitting there watching the
fuzz buzz run across the screen
or the dudes running across and you see
multiple dudes because they can't do
fast motion good right so so let's
let's let's invest in ourselves people
like we are gamers
let's invest in our it's not just one
thing when you go get the console great
you got a playstation five great you got
a series that but does it check those
boxes
is those boxes check and if they're not
then make sure that you get a television
because there are televisions in your
memes that do
check those boxes once you're getting
the most out of your product
that you do have you don't want to have
a a high power this is like going to get
a great graphics card but your cpu
is garbage right so you you have to uh
align your products if this is where you
game and this is your entertainment
please focus on that part and put your
energy into that part so you can get the
most
out of your your systems and your stuff
like that that's that's that's all i got
to say i just try to get the most
out of my devices that's all right
absolutely
one bad mother i bought a 77 x
uh cx with all the money i
saved switch gaining my gaming life to
xbox game pass
two games a month cost more than 24
months financing on an oled
you got a point there man if you want to
upgrade to a new tv
we got a system for you it's called the
xbox series
and you get that game pass and then in
like
in like in like a year you can get that
nice
oled cx 77 inch we're gonna go and end
on there man
uh k mega where can the people find you
at man
man you gotta tell them all that no all
that nice stuff that you got going on
over there
man i appreciate it man thank you guys
for the invite man i really do i do
appreciate it man
especially you know me and eddie we
talked damn all the time i go and i went
into the party with david a couple of
times
why you won't be coming in here i say
man i don't be bothering people man you
better come in here and say what's up
myself
i told i told dealer and other people
man i want to be more open up coming to
jumping in parties and stuff i just
you know i'm just kind of nocturnal like
that but um
but uh yeah you come and check me out on
the grg podcast check out me and the
crew
oh you know 108 dragons bloody uh
six layer uh pk live you know what i'm
saying
in a uh second lady you know i'm saying
to the second first lady to the second
generation
uh miss d you know uh check us out every
friday night 8 pm
central uh 9 p.m eastern uh and i
believe 6 p.m
uh pacific time and 2 a.m uh
you know overseas gm tmt time so yeah
108 uh five dollars super chat uh
man okay i don't know pc i don't know tv
stuff
i'ma try but this is this seems like a
foreign language
someone read that because i will butcher
all of that that that
that's clearly tv stuff yeah he said the
high ends uh
uh g is the best budget tv right now 65
inch
1300 and hdr 120 with dolby vision 120
fps also my boy king always send y'all
to my uh to my channel facts all right
so yeah so yeah go check out one of you
he had to promote brooklyn brooklyn yeah
go check out my boy
dragons tv at the dragons did yeah good
good
good content man good good content good
content uh
also uh fight night sundays uh
every sunday night um we play nothing
but fighters um so if y'all wanna if
you're interested nine pm
uh central time come and come and get it
or just come watch me on twitch at
kmega405 also
every thursday night uh my boy xbox 448
we do the next podcast and that's it
like uh 7 p.m central
and uh yeah man um uh the devin the
gamer we'll be bringing that back and
that's where i can finally get my boy
king david to come on because
to get that schedule so uh me and my boy
the don
and uh we could try to get that popping
but yeah appreciate it man i really do
it's an honor man to be in here amongst
the the realm man
no doubt in in the baby realm
i might have to go back and edit that
out
so king david man you uh
one of the lords from the iop first off
i want to i want to
say that you know people have been
asking yes i'm working with the
logistics we're going to be doing that
extra podcast where
you guys ask us non-gaming related stuff
i got to work the
the logistics out a little bit the
patreon people and the members are going
to be asking the questions
uh we will be making the very first
episode a public factor but the only
questions we are answering
is the people on patreon and the people
our members we got to give you guys some
content man you guys
go above and beyond uh you know but we
will give that first episode to everyone
because we want to show you guys the
quality of that show and the quality of
that product
uh and then after that you'll have to be
on may a
member or a patreon king where can the
people find you right man where
where can they find you at they can find
me sleep until sundays at 1 pm
now um yeah this stuff in the gym is
killing me i'm doing a whole bunch of
different stuff
and you know you just got to try
different things to get different
results and
it's been fun it's a little you know fun
journey that i'm going on
um you can find me at iron lords podcast
sundays at 1 p.m
during football season this is getting
ready to start
[Music]
it's about to be 11 a.m oh my god
oh oh my god i don't know how i'm gonna
deal with that
but uh yeah we have uh um
dcx is coming back uh again soon
in august uh host had to take a little
hiatus a little break on some stuff
uh but be right back there i'm trying to
get myself
on to really real this week with uh
everborn
and uh chaosante uh because i have some
stuff i want to talk about you guys was
on my timeline talking about how he-man
wasn't uh another netflix banger and um
i got words for you
uh because when i did purchase my he-man
toys
i didn't just purchase he-man and
skeletor uh they weren't the focal point
of my my battles my battles was man at
arms my battles
triceratops my battle was skunk man you
know the fact that they did have skunk
man and it blew my mind
right merman you know he is aquaman but
y'all thought he was a a little uh
subservient uh dude that wasn't a boss
he was a boss they showed boss tactics
and these things
so uh i thought that that show
was so amazing for the collectors of
all the toys you know and then it showed
other aspects of it so
at no point in time do i agree with
anybody on a timeline having these
feelings of um
uh what is it toxic masculinity
then you know with these feelings of
inferiority to female
uh heroines actually uh taking the the
role as the hero
so nah i don't agree with you but i will
have something to talk about on
absolutely i made a video talking about
that yesterday yeah i
i totally agree thank you there's no
wokeness about that that was just
good storytelling
that that gave the support characters
love i mean that you can't be one of
these people that
that go and play like a game like mass
effect and then jump in and play all the
story uh the side story missions
for all the side characters and want to
get a better understanding of them and
then [ __ ] about
well yeah it wasn't about complaining
about it you know you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah come on i've
always felt like side characters just as
important as main characters
the best shows that's ever been on tv
the best games that's ever been in
gaming
they've always told them all just as
much and yeah i feel like people
always like to to to really not do that
side stuff
the way and this is coming from me that
don't do that side stuff you know what i
think
um we got a two dollar super chat from
everborn saga okay mega come through
thursday
king might need backup oh he said you
might not know
yo man you know you know you know god in
them i can stand on my square and i can
defend it and
and i'm telling you you might not be
ready for my level of defending because
i've watched
every episode of he-man and i got the
new ones
and i still got the old ones and i'm
going to it's marine
props he hit me up after a podcast once
and he was like
yo man let me cuz you want to talk about
a certain topic but
i was like dude i don't really look at
face i don't look at twitter when i'm
doing it you know what i'm saying yeah
always looking afterwards but
you know we definitely got to get ever
born back on the attic show i don't
definitely enjoy
him and uh you know k meg is always
welcome and uh very appreciative
man in the baby brown bamboo
i definitely appreciate everyone coming
through we're going to go in this uh
uh first off i want to point out yes i
read the comments on the iron lord's
podcast
i i saw you guys say how crispy clean
some of you was making very questionable
comments about my beard that now that i
got this camera and i'm
looking at you sideways now but it is
what it is
you'll be able to yeah they would say
something some
crazy stuff but just to clarify
just to clarify every lord will have
this camera within probably the next
month a month and a half
i was kind of the guinea pig we wanted
to see what type of quality we want
and we get these type of items to
improve the pockets because of the
support you guys get you guys come
through here
the super chat's the lights we're able
to do this stuff and demand a better
product right back into the product it
doesn't go anyplace
else right at all i got game pass thank
you
right right he's like
i was doing some e-bagging on grg like
man that's the right showdown looks good
man i
i mean you know that youtube everybody
gotta go right back into yeah
you know right now next week on on
sunday because
what's funny is when we did this because
we got man i
forgot i don't even know where it is
it's around here somewhere we got
here it is we got the wrong lens so we
got the wrong lens
it was way zoomed in man and i felt
uncomfortable you see
like white nah we ain't talking about
that but you know so we got the
we got a different lens you know that's
what this is here
uh cog will most likely be with the same
camera sunday if we have enough time to
really build it up
and then after me and cog you know we'll
find out everyone likes it
then we got to figure out king because
look at king king is a unique situation
because he wants to all the stuff in the
background but we still want a good
camera so we might have to get
you know we might have to get a good
good lens for king but
i definitely appreciate everyone coming
through man uh this is gaming addict
this is the